the cool thing i want to show  is this player so this is mathematica  notebook  it's basically having a video player  inside of it  and then the cool things we can do is  called video map that is taking  image measurements and it's computing  mean intensity  for each frame we have put a lot of  focus on speech and speaker analysis  which is very exciting  there's going to be a lot of video  editing like trim this video  or trim this part of every video frame  and things like that  this is the most exciting thing all the  audience here at the conference  are asking us about video and i guess  this is really the  next big thing from our team